ein bisschen schlecht willkommen weil
mein video im heutigen video haben wir
was kann es war also der krasseste teil
kommt bei den beiden auf dem panel ist
in der wiederbestellung von links check
das auf jeden fall ab und am ende im
weltcup genau das auch auf jeden fall
spielen wir jetzt wenn ich du wäre im
taxi und wir nerven taxifahrer und
bringen sie zur weist all ihren 50.000
leicht machen wir das auch im flugzeug
wir fangen einfach an die tische
amazon kölner erkannt
das online-seminar
sie müssen aber wissen
[Musik]
hans heuser kommt was rüber ok-chef
finden sie erkannten sie nicht machen
werden sie mich mal auf einer skala von
1 10
kritisch sah ich will jetzt auch durch
dann so in deutschland mit gesang und
rap auch also mache ich schon viel aber
kommt halt noch nicht so gut anderen ich
will jetzt mein gesang überzeugen denn
sie den song a day to day
ist es okay problem
[Musik]
ich habe manchmal so ich schwitze ein
bisschen an den beinen und geschätzt ja
und ich finde es auch einfach irgendwie
egal halt irgendwie freizügig meine
beine zu präsentieren oder soll ich soll
ich den rasierer oder es müsse nun
endlich
keine frage ich hab ganz viel geld dabei
wir haben alle geld haben aber auch
genug geld dabei wer sind für sie okay
wenn man statt geld auch anders bezahlen
kann also ich würde auch irgendwie blöd
oder so anbieten oder irgendwie weiß
dass ich was ich mache da sowas nicht
anhalten
es geht auf die motorhaube ist der
dritte war nicht ganz gut drauf so alles
los ist total schlecht
mir ist total schlecht was jetzt kommen
wir alle mechanismen besser wäre wertlos
waren das nicht versteht ist gerade auch
nicht ganz alex ich war mir gedanken
seitdem ist es passiert ist kann alles
passieren alter wenn ihr klar ist das
kann ich denn dafür heute was ihr euch
eigentlich auf keinen fall vorenthalten
will sind so ein paar sachen wir sind
dann halt noch mit dem anderen
taxifahrer gefahren und der ist wirklich
komplett ausgerastet also das ganze
gibt's auf jeden fall war kann man im
video ist verlinkt am ende habe ich ja
schon erzählt aber ein paar szenen zeigt
euch macht der hat uns der volt uns
schlagen der das rausgeschmissen
der hat mich gepackt er ist komplett
durchgedreht viel spaß
was jetzt kommt ich wollte dir beide
jetzt für ständig stellen wie weizen
oder so
keine ahnung ich weiß nicht wer erzogen
wurde heiko es geht mit ihr euch in
giftigen wir jetzt raus können so einer
der jungen freiheit auf der stelle
was die kurz auch wenn er noch mal
loswerden wollte es ist natürlich so
eine sache so man kann es jetzt auch
eventuell so sind ihr seid voll a7 sowas
macht man nicht einfach wenn ich du wär
ich finde es witzig und der taxifahrer
bei uns gegenüber dann auch ziemlich
schnell sehr aggressiv was man zum teil
natürlich verstehen kann
aber jan im tumor und ich hoffe ihr habt
genauso gedacht wie wir also es war auf
jeden fall mega witzig ich hoffe
natürlich erst hat euch gefallen und
checkt auf jeden fall den heftigeren
partner der es auf jeden fall bei heiko
man auch einen keller also da wirklich
komplett übertrieben das müsst ihr euch
geben es einfach mal hier verlinkt ist
wahrscheinlich sehen oder oben in der
video beschreibung ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen wie schon gesagt check ins netz
ab abonniert mich würd mich freuen wir
sind morgen wieder neues video und so
haut rein